Como prevenir adultos e crianças de
pneumonias que a gente está ouvindo
falar. Olha só, pessoal, eu tô vendo
muita gente preocupada com essas
pneumonias que andam aparecendo por aí.
E não é para menos, viu? Com esse surto
de metapneemovírus lá na China, que o
Ministério da Saúde tá de olho e já com
casos aqui registrados em Pernambuco,
todo mundo fica meio assim, né,
preocupadíssimo. Outro dia mesmo, uma
paciente minha chegou no consultório
super aflita, porque a vizinha dela
estava internada com pneumonia. E aí ela
me perguntou: "Doutor, o que eu faço
para não pegar isso?" Pois é, vamos
bater um papo sobre isso hoje, porque
prevenir é sempre melhor que remediar,
óbvio, né, pessoal? Sabe o que que é
curioso? A pneumonia não é uma doença
nova, ela sempre existiu. É uma
inflamação dos pulmões, geralmente
causado por bactérias, vírus e até
fungos. Imagina seus pulmões como duas
esponjas que ficam enchendo e esvaziando
de ar o tempo todo. Quando esses
microrganismos invadem, é como se a
esponja ficasse encharcada, dificulta
para respirar e aí vem aquela tosse,
febre, falta de ar. Nada legal. E olha
que interessante, depois da pandemia, os
médicos já esperavam um aumento desses
casos. Por quê? Porque nós ficamos muito
tempo isolados e o nosso sistema de
defesa ficou destreinado, ficou
enferrujado. OK? Agora eu vou te contar
uma coisa que muita gente não sabe. A
maioria das pneumonias a gente pega não
é de outra pessoa diretamente, é isso
mesmo. Muitas vezes são bactérias que já
moram na nossa boca e nariz. os
colonizadores normais, como a gente
chama na medicina, que aproveitam quando
a nossa imunidade dá uma baixada e
descem pro pulmão. É tipo aquele parente
chato que aproveita quando você tá de
bobeira e se instala na sua casa. Sabe
como é que é? Mas calma, não precisa
entrar em pânico. Tem muita coisa que dá
para fazer para se proteger. Primeiro
vamos falar do básico, que todo mundo já
tá careca de saber, mas que funciona
mesmo. Lavar as mãos, gente, é sério.
Lavar as mãos direito, com água e sabão,
esfregando por uns 20 segundos. O tempo
de cantar parabéns para você duas vezes
já elimina a maioria dos germes. E olha,
não é só passar uma aguinha, não. Tem
que esfregar entre os dedos, as unhas, o
doço das mãos, fazer o serviço completo
mesmo. E tem uma novidade importante.
Com esse tal de metapnemovirrus
circulando por aí, o uso de máscara
voltou a ser recomendado em algumas
circunstâncias, por exemplo, locais
fechados e com muita gente. Eu não saia
usando máscara na rua em espaço aberto.
não vale a pena, não precisa usar o
tempo todo, então, mas naquele ônibus
lotado ou numa sala de espera cheia,
vale a pena. E abrir janelas também
ajuda para caramba. Ventilação é
fundamental. Outra coisa fundamental é
manter o sistema imune em dia. E como a
gente faz isso? Primeiro, dormindo bem.
Nosso corpo precisa de umas 7 a 8 horas
de sono por noite para produzir as
células de defesa direitinho. É durante
o sono que nosso organismo faz a
manutenção do sistema imune. Então nada
de ficar virando à noite no celular, ok?
Alimentação também é chave, viu? precisa
comer comida de verdade, frutas,
verduras, legumes, proteínas de
qualidade, vitamina C, vitamina D,
zinco, tudo isso fortalece a nossa
imunidade. E olha que interessante, alho
e gengibre, aqueles remedinhos da vovó,
tem propriedades antimicrobianas
comprovadas cientificamente.
Então, pode caprichar naquele chazinho
de gengibre com limão. Ah, e tem uma
coisa que pouca gente fala, a higiene
dos narizes, a nasal, principalmente nas
crianças que ainda não sabem a suar o
nariz direito. Usar o soro fisiológico
para lavar o narizinho ajuda muito a
eliminar secreções onde as bactérias
adoram se multiplicar. É simples, barato
e super eficaz. Pro pessoal mais velho
ou com doenças crônicas, o cuidado tem
que ser redobrado. Diabetes, doenças
cardíacas, DPOC, tudo isso aumenta o
risco. Então, além de tudo que já falei,
é importante manter essas condições bem
controladinhas. E olha, quando você tem
alguma infecção viral, fica fácil uma
bactéria oportunista causar uma
pneumonia depois. Então, é tipo deixar a
porta aberta pro ladão entrar, ok? E
sabe o que mais?
Parar de fumar, obviamente é essencial.
Cigarro é tipo um tapete vermelho pros
gêmeos entrarem no pulmão. Paralisa os
cílios, aqueles pelinhos microscópicos
que varrem a sujeira para fora dos
pulmões. Sem eles funcionando direito, é
festa pra bactéria do mal. Uma última
dica de ouro, atividade física regular,
exercício moderado, fortalece o sistema
imunológico, melhora a circulação, ajuda
a eliminar toxinas, é remédio natural,
não precisa virar atleta, ok? Uma
caminhada de 30 minutos por dia já faz
uma diferença danada. E olha, com os
dados que saíram agora em 2025, a gente
viu que o Brasil tem mais de 600.000
internações por ano por pneonia e gripe
juntas. É muita coisa, mas seguindo
essas orientações, dá para reduzir em
muito esse número. Então é isso,
pessoal. Prevenir pneumonia não tem
segredo, é cuidado básico, higiene,
alimentação, sono, exercício, zinco,
vitamina D, vitamina C. ficar atento aos
sinais do corpo. Se aparecer tosse
persistente, febre, falta de ado ou no
peito, não fique esperando melhorar
sozinho, não. Mas seguindo essas dicas,
a chances de você e sua família ficarem
bem protegidos aumenta bastante. Vamos
cuidar da nossa saúde com carinho,
porque ela é o nosso bem mais precioso,
ok? Até a próxima. Se cuidem.
Compartilhe os vídeos, faça bem. A vida
de alguém pode mudar também no canal do
Doutor, Além do Tr se volvar.